let me tell you something folks you
can't fix stupid
that is comedian Ron White taking aim at
his ex-wife in his act famously called
you can't fix yeah that act was a huge
hit for the comedian and he since
married a new woman and tonight he's
showing us what life is like for him on
the road you've seen one woman naked do
you want to see the rest of it he's a
hit with Taylor Swift Sheryl Crow and
the Biebs catches sold-out shows and
he's pals with the guy who discovered
him comedian Jeff Foxworthy
it's like what we call tater ground
tater salad has turned blue collar
comedy into big bucks he's worth a
reported 10 million dollars and travels
in the Margeaux raid named after his
third wife I think what makes me
different is economic is that I'm just
through my nature and then I smoke and
drink like a fish his bus has a fully
stocked bar shower beds and of course a
humidor you'll notice there are no Cuban
cigars in there because I would never do
anything he's not American his smoke
Adisa cigar white grew up in the tiny
town of frig Texas did a stint in the
Navy and has a 21 year old son he spent
20 years honing his comedy lax Goudy
screening and this guy's just losing
because I guess it couldn't travel that
much you're not used to this equipment
you know you can have fun with that you
can do what I do I take two viagra and
demand a pat-down
Ron's humor has earned him two Grammy
nominations three number-one comedy TV
specials and now there's a little
unprofessional download available on Ron
White special comp the five bucks you
can download it watch it on your
television computer your tablet
smartphone even your blender silly you
duct tape your smartphone to your
blender or it just won't work white is
forever grateful to Foxworthy says hey
you're really playing but you need to
put the pipeline anything into the joke
he said then say that and then stare at
him in there laughing
I've been doing it that way we've just
golf for a long time to make me a famous
comedian they truly like Santa cuz it
took him forever you know as you can see
Ron very busy on the road he also had a
part in Jennifer Aniston's Horrible
Bosses so he is a man of the stage and
film in the small screen he's busy and
he's raking in down the hot commodity
yes he is alright still ahead